je l'évité parce qu'il a fait ça fait
longtemps que je le connais depuis 2011
enquête dont un de première festival
nomade social rien et je voulais
toujours avoir la présence autochtone
dans ce festival puisque c'est que vie
nomade que partagée par tous ces
premières nations autochtones et aux
autres qu'on retrouvera la foulée
et cette fois-ci j'aimerais vraiment que
commence à vraiment faire de dialogue
entre les nations puis se trouve ici au
canada avec celle qu'il se trouve en
afrique
celle qui se trouve laide ainsi décrit
un dialogue pour permettre ces
populations à mieux vivre changé entre
les idées et trouver des solutions
simples pour vouloir modifier le débit
c'est cette soirée qu'on fait ici à
marianne2 mais après on va faire tout un
trajet pour traverser les deux heures un
chameau ankara avait à la rue on va
appuyer amaury
nous on va chanter on va danser et de
festivals c'est vraiment basé sur le
partage sur aussi de valeurs qui nous
rassemblent tous sur le bonheur sur bien
manger bien danser bien vivre